as coronavirus spread in the u.s. one of
the things that coronavirus does is it
gets into your lungs and it makes it
hard to breathe and so an increasing
number of people were ending up with
Kovac 19 in the ICUs needing to go onto
ventilators and the u.s. didn't have a
lot of ventilators there was a report by
Johns Hopkins that said that the u.s.
had about 160,000 of them that sounds
like a lot in normal times but it isn't
right now as this was happening there
were discussions back and forth about
what was happening in key industries and
especially auto manufacturing around
mid-march you had the major US auto
manufacturers realizing they were
probably gonna have to start shutting
down plants and in one case the Ford
Motor Company CEO Jim Hackett while he
was talking with White House staff about
the likely impact of the corona virus
from the auto industry sort of just
blurted out you know maybe Ford should
should help make some ventilators
because there's this recognition of the
the big shortage between what we have
and what we're likely to need different
companies are talking to medical device
manufacturers trying to figure out well
how exactly could we maybe help you know
fill this gap and help expand production
of these devices pretty quickly how do
you get disparate pieces to be assembled
and moved out Automotive has perfected
doing this with just-in-time
you know so that you aren't sitting on
billions of dollars of inventory and to
try and create that from scratch so we
had no relationships we did an amazing
job we were appalled General Motors is
working with Ventech a new player in the
medical device industry that has a very
highly regarded compact portable
ventilator Ford teamed up with GE
healthcare and a Ron a small Florida
company that has
a relatively low cost and easy to build
model in the case of the car makers
which are losing money right now because
they're not manufacturing vehicles and
auto sales have just tanked they're
really not making any money on these
ventilator projects in each case both
General Motors and Ford are simply
trying to have their costs covered to
set up and establish these new
production lines on-site at their
factories we're not looking for a
contract
we'd like can we have a verbal agreement
that will come we'll be really
transparent and ethical about about the
cost and we really don't want to profit
from this if GM Ford said it's just not
the time to profit they said yeah you
know tell us what you need and we said
well we'll follow up with you on that I
think that created the air of you know
Ford's just trying to make this happen
and they'll settle up at the end
Ford's goal with Iran is to produce 50
thousand ventilators by July 4th in GM's
partnership with Ventech the company has
a basic goal of getting to 10,000 units
a month that it's producing out of a
Kokomo Indiana Auto Parts plant the
company also has a contract with the US
Department of Health and Human Services
to deliver 30,000 of the devices for the
national stockpile by the end of August
GM was one of those phone calls that
immediately went from a conversation and
went from zero to 60 very quickly it was
immediately understood that they could
bring a lot to the table as far as
helping us with supply chain and
bringing on new suppliers to source
parts more quickly Jim also understands
mass manufacturing mass production
ventilator manufacturers tend to
manufacture ventilators that lead
thousands per month we immediately
started thinking outside the box how can
we ramp up our production our supply
changes to give you a perspective we
build an f-150 every 52 seconds this is
a machine that the prices are 70 to 100
thousand dollars per copy so it's it's
as or
more complex in a ventilator for both
General Motors and Ford this has meant
quickly securing some new manufacturing
equipment setting up new machines
training workers how to operate those
machines and making sure that everything
is up to the necessary medical standards
specifications that are required for
ventilators there's a very complex
supply chain for ventilators each teeth
that goes into it is made by a different
subcontractor so it's not just like it's
one manufacturer that's making the
ventilator its the ventilator
manufacturer relying on this entire
ecosystem of qualified subcontractors
each manufacturer would have their
specific line and what their capacity is
for the day and one way of increasing
your capacity is going to a second shift
or a third shift every time that you add
to the system it goes back to your
quality and all of that needs to be
tracked according to the quality system
set up by the FDA there's a quality
system that you have to meet and you
have to take the time to do the
documentation or a ventilator for a life
support system like a ventilator if you
were brand new and hadn't had a
ventilator in the marketplace it
probably takes about 18 months you know
to go through that process it's been a
lot of talk about ventilators a lot of
very well-intentioned very smart people
building ventilators overnight but a
ventilator particularly a critical care
ventilator is much more than just moving
air in and out you're giving the patient
too much air and you're overinflating
that lungs you can cause harm or death
and if you're under inflating the lungs
you can cause harm or death to the
patient eventually there will be a
sufficient supply of ventilators but
it's going to be very delayed these are
complicated devices they're not going to
be ready in April more will be available
in May June July and
as the months go on so that's the good
news that places that will have a
greater need in the months ahead the
supplies will be better for them it's a
real problem right now for places like
New York and New Jersey that really have
an enormous demand